me
医師の
ます
皆さん
突然ですが
クイズです
僕は今
何に一番ハマっているでしょうか
服ラーメン巡りも好きなんですが
ラーメン巡りは答えではありません
すー
浮くランニングも好きなんですけどランニングは答えではありません
さあ何でしょうか
なんでしょうねぇ
を食べましたう
さあ
答えなんですか
温泉ですわかり音声のやっぱ
パンフレットとか動画見てここに間ずいうって書いてあっておけまで
キロりんの大きいまで用意しましたからね
ってだけで温泉が好きな19歳です
僕なんですが
長野県の大学に所属している温泉同好会です
そんな僕なんですが今日は皆さんに
on と off
について話したいと思っていますそれを僕が好きな温泉にちょっと
絡めて話していきたいとおもいます
でもどうして音とふと温泉が
関係してくるんだろうなっていうふうに疑問に思ってる人もいるんじゃないかという
ふうに思います
ですのでまず
僕が
温泉からもらった
音の話を僕のちょっとしたヒストリーを話していこうと思います
まあ皆さん
温泉の話ですので肩の力を抜いてリラックスして
それにあの皆さんがみなさんに覚えていただけるようにいろんなところに
言葉遊びの工夫をいじったのでところどころで笑ってくだされば
同じです
ってだけで
僕が温泉からもらった音の話入っていきたいとおもいます
突然ですがみなさん
自分が今高校3年生だというふうに仮定してみてください
あなたは今高校3年生で今週末
部活で県大会県大会を控えています
そして
来週には生徒総会があって
自分はその生徒総会の長としてへ
その生徒総会の運営を進めていかなければいけません
すれば忘れていました今週はずっとテストがあるんです
高校3年生なので受験にむけて this と勉強していかなければいけません
もう何から手をつければいいかやらなければいけないことが多すぎて
なんか結構切羽詰まってくるんですね
こういう風になってくると
これ
実は僕の実はでもあって
僕は陸上部に所属していて実はこう見えて
100メートルを10秒台で走ることができるのです
なので練習もすごくハードでそれに生徒会長でもあったのですごくいろんなやらなけれ
ばいけないことに追われていました
でも
これは僕のただの例ですが皆さんにも何かしらー
やらなければいけないことっていうのはあると思います
このやらなければいけない事っていうのが溜まってくると頑張らなきゃ段原なきゃって
いうふうに思いますよね
頑張らないといけないと
そういう念に駆られてしまいます
当時の僕もそうでした
僕は
今からその当時の僕のことを振り返ってみると頑張っていたのではなく
かたくなを張っていたと言うように思います
このかたくなを張っていたっていうのはどういうことかというと
やらなければいけないとか
自分のポリシーを回りてはならないみたいなそんな
校
カッチカチの精神
全然心に余裕の無い状態です
そういうのが
続いていたんですね
その心に余裕がない状態っていうものが続いてくると
新しいアイディア法律的なアイデアっていうものも生まれなくなってきます
あのとき僕は頑張ることを大切にして頑張ろう頑張ろうっていうふうにしていましたが
客観的に見れば多分視野が狭くなっていて
あの人何やってんだろうみたいなパフォーマンスを客観的に見れば
落としていたんじゃないかというふうに思います
そんなとき
父が
お前顔色悪いぞって言って温泉に集ってくれました
当時の僕はやらなければいけないことに追われていても早く練習位
少しでもしなきゃとか仕事早く終わらせなきゃって思って
そんな余裕ないよっていう風な態度を取っていたんですが
まあこの時
温泉に連れていったも連れて行ってもらったことが僕にとって大きなターニング
ポイントになりました
ここ
長野県が温泉大国だったことが幸いしたのかもしれません
露天風呂からは壮大な景色を眺めることができていっ
温泉に入った瞬間に
心の中の頑ながほぐれていくようなそんな気がしました
音声は成分表にこそ書いてありませんが
陸上とかの筋肉痛だけではなく心にも
も安らぎと余裕を与えてくれました
この時僕は溶け出していった僕
の中でやらなければいけない事っていうのを一つ一つ
認識してで1つ1つに対してしっかりと考えることができたんです
ここ
こういう風にすれば弾能力進むなとかここはこの人に任せるのが最適だなということを
一歩引いた目から客観的に分析することができました
この時僕が痛感したのは
オフなくして良いアイデアは生まれないということです
どんどん頑張ろう頑張ろうっていう風な気持ちでいる頑張ることは大切なことだと思い
ます
しかし
女はずっと動き続けていれば
新しいアイディア創造的なアイデアっていうのは
ちょっと館で来ないんじゃないかなというふうに思ったんです
それで今回
僕が
その教訓から
皆さんに伝えたいっ
そのキャッチフレーズがこちらになります
賢くお風呂
んでっ
賢い皆さんならどうして僕がをフローって u ターン使っているかもう分かっている
と思うのでこれ以上は言いませんが
た四国を振ろう
これはどういうことかと言いますと
簡単なことなんです非常にシンプルなアイデアなんです
ちゃんと自分にオフを与えてあげること
on と off の状態をちゃんと意識すること
それだけでいい鉄
オフがあってこそのおっこれを意識するだけでいいんです
僕は人は2曲の中で揺れ動きながら生活しているっていうふうに思っていて例えば
寝ては起きるスっては吐くというように人はこうオンとオフの間を波のように揺れ動き
ながら生活しています
温泉にちゃんと使ったときに生じる並みの用意
この波のようなライフスタイルから何が生まれているかっていうとこちらになります
とっ
フロー
ブーン
まだちょっと賢い皆さんなら分かっていると思うのでちょっとこれ以上は言いませんが
でもこの風呂っていうのは後をつけていった単語ではなくこの中にもいろいろな意味が
あって
生じる起こる感情が沸き起こる
よどみなく流れるという意味を含んでいます
最初の地点はいつだってオフなんです
そこからフローが生まれてそして音になっていく
このフローっていうのは実はゼロから
0.0001ゼロから無から有会の超越というかそのひらめきを生んでくれる
そういうものを僕がフローっていう風に言っています
まぁちょっと規模が大きい話になるかもしれませんが
まあ例えば宇宙だって最初は何もない状態からビッグバンが起きてそれでまあいろいろ
なものがバレたわけです
なので新しいものを作り出す力はオフの状態に
チャンスが眠っているっていうことを皆さんにはぜひ
ちょっと今日覚えて帰ってほしいなというふうに思うんです
このオフが flow 3音を生む
このサイクルを意識するだけで僕たちの生活の中で結構アイデアって生まれてくるん
ですよ
僕が実際に体験したのはそのこのオフの状態を大切にすることで高
おおおおぉもっと頑張ろうとか今まで感じたことないか思う
音のパフォーマンスを向上させるっていうそういう意識がちゃんと生まれたんですね
これはすごく大きなことだと思います
僕にとってのオフは温泉です
皆さんにとってのオフは
何ですか
このプレゼンをきっかけに
皆さんにとってのオフを探してみる
または再定義してみるのもいいかもしれません
最後になりますが
前に言ったように
賢くを振ろうというのは難しいことではありません
自分が今
頑張りすぎているなちょっと心に余裕がないなっていうふうに感感じたときは
ぜひ自分にオフを与えてあげてください
そしてぜひ周りに
か2の僕のように頑張らなきゃ頑張らなきゃっていうふうに視野が狭くなっている
心に余裕がないだっていう人がいたらぜひ
賢くお風呂
っていう風に言って
提案してあげてください
このアイデアがー
波のように広がっていって
色々な人に新たなアイディアをもたらしてくれることを願ってプレゼンをおしまいにし
たいと思います
ありがとうございました
[拍手]